okay so what has culminated in a long
and tiring election season I had to say
after it's all said and done and I think
most of us are relieved that it's all
said and done I have to say one thing
that stands out to me is just how proud
I am to be an American
make no mistake of it this election
reflected a popular revolt this is a
populist revolt and in any other nation
in the world it would not have gone like
this there were no bullets fired
there's no rioting there's no cities
burning down the way that our people
express their opinions is they go to the
polls and they vote and for an entire
group of people that for far too long
have felt ignored and left behind some
of whom were labeled the undereducated
they're human beings trying to make a
living raise their kids working two or
three jobs and they felt ignored by a
system and they get to express their
opinions by voting is open the next day
whether your candidate won or your
candidate lost
there's no rights there's no cities
burning to the ground in England when
they had brexit the leaders gloated in
France sometimes when things go the
wrong way they riot we are not doing
that and those are other democracies I
am so proud to be an American now we
still have to go back and we still have
to take some accountability for this
insane election cycle that we had I
believe we get the leaders we deserve I
think they are a mirror reflection of us
and it's not just them who are divided
and divisive and narcissistic and want
to put their self-interest ahead of the
greater good who are short term estates
us that's how we're running our
businesses we are short terms we're the
narcissists we're the divisive ones
we're the ones who aren't listening I
think we need to be the leaders we wish
we had we have to practice good
leadership we cannot all be victims of a
system we have to be the leaders we wish
we had we have
to be more inclusive we have to try and
understand everyone's fears and
insecurities not just one group or
another if someone expresses anger
instead of reacting to the symptoms we
have to say are you okay tell me what
you're feeling we need to be the ones
who need to improve our listening skills
and I think this election proves it
everybody was talking at each other and
nobody was trying to understand the
stresses and strains of their life and
why they chose the candidate they chose
I'm still proud to be an American and we
have a tradition in America that the
winner is gracious and the loser
concedes graciously as well and we've
done that we have a tradition in America
that whether your candidate won or your
candidate lost we band together as
Americans and we say I will support our
president until our president gives me a
reason not to yes it was an embarrassing
embarrassing election regardless of who
won and yes there are things that we are
all embarrassed and ashamed of but
that's it
this is the system we have and this is
the president we have and we must
support our president when he's your
candidate or not whether he's my
candidate or not we are American we are
optimists this is the reason I choose to
live in America I don't want to move to
Canada I came here from another place I
chose to become a citizen why because I
love American optimism we can withstand
everything and we can grow together let
us prove to our candidates let us prove
to future candidates what leadership
looks like let us be the example and
stop demanding that they be the sole
example let us show them how we take
care of each other how we listen how
we're inclusive of those with whom we
disagree it makes for better companies
it makes for a better families it makes
for better schools it makes for better
churches it makes for better communities
I love this country I love that the
system worked I love that there's no
violence in the streets and we will have
a peaceful
transfer of power for the 45th time
that's amazing and I think with your
candidate one or your candidate lost we
have to remember that this is our system
and it works so let us stand together
let us be the leaders we wish we had let
us work hard ourselves to prove and to
make sure that future elections are
civilized in the open-minded and
inclusive and there's a listening that's
what I really hope that the future looks
nothing like what we just went through
we're all exhausted